[Music]
this
is star talk cosmic queries edition
special live at the broward county
youth climate summit the third annual so
we're delighted to be a part of that
i've got with me my co-host chuck nice
chuck
hey neil so obviously while i know a
little bit about climate i don't know
anything
near who we've got here as guests yeah a
very important addition to this
because for cosmic queries we want to
make sure we have the right expertise
at the right time at the right place
which is now
i've got gavin schmidt gavin welcome
back to star talk
hi neil chuck nice to be back hey
excellent and and you recently became
seen in addition to being director of
the goddard institute for space studies
which is a a nasa satellite office in
manhattan
many people don't know about that one um
they know about kennedy space center and
you know and and and uh in houston
but uh we've got a little pocket of nasa
in new york city and you're there as our
neighbors so
good to know that but you're also uh uh
elevated or
or is is this a promotion i guess to
senior advisor on climate to nasa
so it's nice to know that such a
position exists
uh because it's more than just now yes
it does it does now
yes it's it's not good enough just to
research on climate this stuff has to
get communicated
and if you're an advisor to nasa and
nasa is a hugely public entity
in our lives not only domestically but
in the world
you've got a really key place there and
let me just lead off before we get to
the questions that no chuck has
collected
because that's the the the dna of this
format
is questions from you from from the
public
coming back to get answered in our
startalkian
way but let me just ask you gavin
should we not be surprised that this
youth climate summit
is being organized in florida
uh and not colorado or one of the
mountain states
if you can tell us what what special
relationship
florida has with climate change well
you know florida is ground zero for uh
the impacts of uh things like sea level
rise
coastal flooding um greater intensity of
hurricanes
and so you know we're seeing we're
seeing changes in in the in the
temperature of the sea
uh around uh florida we're seeing
changes in the storm climate
um and we're seeing sea level rise and
uh
and that puts florida very much at the
uh
a grand zero for the really acute
impacts of climate change that's
happening now uh
not least uh the things that may be
happening in the future
you know i remember seeing was it not
last year but perhaps the year before
uh there was one a satellite photo of
hurricanes
all lined up ready to slam into florida
it was like okay your turn it was like
they were lining up at the deli
right and i i just have no memory of
seeing such
um such persistence of assault
yeah on a coastline i mean 2020 was a
very bad year for hurricanes a very very
active uh
atlantic season um i think 2015 was that
was the previous one that was that was
uh no 2000 2005 was was
was a really big year too um and uh
that's not what you expect every year
thankfully
um uh but uh we are seeing we are seeing
trends in uh you know
caribbean hurricanes we're seeing more
those are being more frequent they're
they're more intense when they uh
when they arise we're seeing increases
in you know cat 345
uh hurricanes and we think that that's
being fueled
by the warmer temperatures uh in the
uh in the tropical atlantic uh and
places so yeah so it's uh
uh that was very that that was very
sobering well
chuck did you hear he's on a first name
basis with the hurricane
level cat five yes
i'm just saying we're not we're not a
dad to me it's still a floating gardener
uh one last thing before we run over to
chuck and get some questions from our
from our fan base and the audience um
that have been
pre-collected the the um in in
last year 2020 i heard there was like
hurricane
alpha and i thought to myself alpha did
we run
out of letters of the alphabet to name
these words we're starting to use
the greek alphabet so what's up with
that i didn't know that was in
in the in the regular rules that's
exactly right yeah so the the national
weather service uh has a list of
uh pre-approved names and they have it
for i think out for another five years
uh it does it's not every letter of the
alphabet but i think it's it's
20 23 uh um
names that might not be quite right but
once you've run out of those then you
start doing these
these greek alphabets uh alpha beta uh
gamma delta uh epsilon i mean
uh and so when you're seeing uh
hurricane alpha you know it's been a bad
season
wow yeah and now why only 23
uh of the letters i mean uh what names
did they
omit that are just so awful that we
could
they hate the letters so there's never
been a hurricane xavier
um and uh no
yeah so there's no there's no x's and i
i i you know i should have checked on
this before i came on
i i don't know the rest of that we can
uh okay we can we can assign that as
homework perhaps for the
i'm looking forward to hurricane yvonne
you know you gotta you need to modernize
the names right yeah exactly
absolutely they they do modernize the
names i mean so
it used to be all very anglo names you
know
arthur and charlie and and they always
used to be male and then they
then they started mixing it up now it's
male and female and now they're also
taking names from uh
from a broader cultural background so is
that is a good or a bad thing
in a way it's a good thing because it
means that we're recognizing that
there's
cultural diversity but in a way it's a
bad thing because you're being named
after a hurricane
it's like you know i don't want to i
don't you know in a way
it's hurricane chuck right she's
battering the seaboard
hurricane rashiniqua like you know
and then what if it's like the worst
hurricane ever and it's like a black
name
you know what i mean just like oh of
course hurricane
la damian gotta be the worst hurricane
ever like
[Laughter]
so chuck let's let's let's do this jack
all right let's just jump what do you
have for us
of course all these uh questions come
from the students of uh broward county
and uh i uh i think let's start with
aidan m and uh let me see here aidan
oh my goodness trade what do you have
aidan's great grade and what school
there is he is engraved
that trade wins elementary okay
so uh and he says this it's a great
question
who first noticed global warming
which is a great question because people
may think it's a
relatively new phenomenon uh so
uh so the answer to that is actually
actually goes back a a long time
uh there was a guy called calendar
interestingly enough in the 1930s
uh who was the first person to uh put
together a time
series of temperatures um and
with his knowledge of what happens in
the atmosphere and the and the important
role
of of carbon dioxide uh he had
hypothesized that he should be able to
see
a trend and he was working in in the
kind of mid 30s
so 1938 i think uh and and he put
together this uh this data set which
uh was was pretty sparse uh but it was
enough to see
that that indeed the temperatures had
changed from
the the beginning of the of the 20th
century so about 1900 through to 1930
um and he said uh yes oh look it seems
to be getting warmer
and this is something that we expect to
happen because
the physics of this had been worked out
in the victorian era in the in the 19th
century so
and people knew that we were burning a
lot of coal we were burning a lot of oil
and we were expecting things to happen
and happen
they did but yeah no it was in the it
was in the 1930s that people
uh started to notice uh what was going
on and then we ignored it for
for another 30 years
and that's working out great right you
know
it's like yeah how's that working out
for you we find out that we are indeed
warming the planet and we go
we'll get to it at some point
but i want to drive my car wow oh man
forget about the earth i'm going to
drive my car but of course if there is
no earth you can't drive your car
so people got to work out the causes and
effects of your desires there
all right chuck what else you got for me
and um
let's go to camila b who is
at sixth grade in indian ridge
middle school hello camilla and camilla
asked this how fast
are glaciers and icebergs
melting
camilla has a sense of urgency she's
like look i need to know what is going
down
right because i'm here in florida
and i need to know so if i should move
so uh you know i mean you've heard the
phrase right glacially slow
right to mean something really moving so
slowly that you can't even see what's
going on
well glacially slow does not mean what
it used to mean
right so i haven't heard i haven't heard
that term
used in that way in at least 10 years oh
it's moving at a glacial pace no one
says that anymore
that's that's amazing because we know
deep down
we are moving those puppies and melting
them down okay go on i'm sorry
interrupted uh yes
no no that's fine i mean you're right
nobody says glacially slow anymore
because the glaciers are really moving
quite fast uh
what we do uh at nasa is that we can
keep track of
how much water and ice there is on
on greenland or in antarctica um and
we have we have these records that
they're measuring the gravity of the
planet and uh
and when the ice uh melts then the
gravity goes down a little bit and we
can
we can track that from space which is
pretty impressive quite frankly
just to be clear gavin we know the
gravity of earth as a
as a collective body when you say nasa
is measuring gravity
you mean they're measuring the
difference in gravity
from one part of earth's surface to the
other is isn't that what you're you're
talking about
yeah so that's something that over time
in one place than another
it's going to have slightly extra
gravity there rather than here
right that's right so so there's more
gravity above a mountain
than there is over the ocean uh and
there's more gravity above a big ice
sheet than over a little ice sheet
and so as the ice sheets shrink uh then
the gravity goes down a little bit and
you can calculate how much
mass has disappeared from the ice and
has gone into the ocean
um and so we we keep track of that and
uh and we can measure
uh for instance the uh the loss of mass
from from green land it's about
250 giga tons of water
every year is is leaving greenland and
it's about 150
of water every year that's leaving
antarctica mostly from the antarctic
peninsula and
west antarctica which is the the bit
which is
if you go all the way down uh through
south america
to the the bit that sticks out that's
the peninsula and then the bit
just to the side of that is uh west
antarctica so most of the massin
is ten to the nine billion ton two to
two 250 billion tons
that's right every every year every year
wow
that's a lot of water and and and that
water
is so that's fresh water going
into salt water that can't be good right
yeah yeah so so that's fresh water from
the land that's going into the ocean and
it raises sea level it gets
it does get spread out mostly evenly
around the ocean
uh and that's adding uh about a
millimeter
per year in global sea level um and the
the total amount of sea level is is made
up of that uh plus
plus changes in mountain glaciers
they're melting quite quickly
and then the warming of the ocean itself
uh is also
causing the the sea level to rise so the
the sea level rise right now is about
just over three millimeters a year um
which doesn't sound like a lot but it's
uh it's been it's been about a foot uh
around uh around florida in the last
in the last 60 to 100 years i'd say and
what i try to tell people is
if you fill a glass completely with
water and then add three millimeters
one hundred percent of what you add
[Laughter]
just let's let's understand that um and
also
uh there's another issue here right
where if you're adding
fresh water at large rates to salt water
that changes the sort of the circulation
patterns and the sea level mix
that previously relied and evolved on it
was what was a stable uh
salt mixture is that is that correct
right so uh so the changes in fresh
water uh
so so fresh water is lighter than salt
water so it tends to sit on the top at
least to start with before it gets mixed
down
uh that changes how easy it is for for
heat to get into the ocean
for carbon to get into the ocean and so
one of the things that we've seen
uh in the oceans as things have warmed
up and we've got this extra fresh water
is that it's becoming harder
to get things down into the ocean and
that's heat and carbon and so that's
actually adding to
the temperatures in the atmosphere it's
adding to the carbon in the atmosphere
uh and so it's actually uh that that's
not a good news that's not good
sorry wow all right all right chuck keep
it keep them coming chuck
yeah this is just going to get more and
more depressing i'm sorry no
you better have something positive to
say at the end of this all right
the last time we're inviting you on
something like this actually i'm going
to
mark sean d for uh to come back to
because it's a great question but it's
too depressing after that answer
so i i can't i cannot ask him
after that answer so let's go to
um uh let's go to maya
e and maya e is in grade five at trade
winds hi
maya and she says what can we do
as kids to slow down the global warming
process
so here's something that's uh a little
more encouraging and
hopeful you've got to remember that
you're not just a kid
right you are a a a
son or a daughter you are a classmate
you
are an advocate you are uh a consumer
um but you're you're all of these things
and one of the most
impressive things that's happened over
the last couple of years uh related to
climate is
is the outpouring of uh
activity and concern uh from
from youth climate leaders like greta
thundberg and
and alex villa senor
who have uh kind of taken this and
really pushed it they pushed it
to you know the the top tables that to
the un
to to government uh decision makers and
and made it
very very clear that it's not okay just
to sit around and not do anything it's
it's not okay
uh to know that this is the crisis and
and not
act in a commensurate way um and
there's been an enormous amount of you
know truly authentic
um uh you know concerns about
about your future i mean speaking
speaking to the youth i mean not
so much my future but your future you
know this is going to be
the issue of your entire lives it's it's
not going to go away next year it's not
going to go away in 10 years time
uh it's going to be a very very real
issue for for all of that time and and
your role
um as as somebody uh
who as people who can who can get uh
the grown-ups and the decision makers to
act in your
interest um is is really very important
so so yes i mean you can encourage you
know local recycling you can encourage
uh renewable energy you can encourage
your school
to uh to have a you know a zero waste
cafeteria all of these things are good
uh and positive steps what you're saying
gavin is
that even if someone in middle school
does not have power of title
or power of of any other
sort of high-ranking official uh you
have the power
that you have social and cultural power
because
if you're if you're 12 years old and you
write a letter to the editor of the
local paper
that you're concerned i bet they're
going to publish it and so you can have
influence beyond
title because because when if
if the 10 year old start worrying about
how the adults are messing up the
environment
that's something to take notice of and
so
oh yeah yeah it makes it makes the
adults feel bad
and uh you know what kids should make
adults feel bad because they absolutely
feel better start guilting your parents
kids
start guilting your mom dad
you don't love me you don't love me look
at what you're doing
look at what you're doing to the planet
mom dad you don't love me
you guys suck you suck grown up
suck grown up suck
that bad be less productive i think
chuck
has chuck has three kids what are the
ages of your kids chuck
uh i have a 20 year old and then
i have a 14 year old and then i have a
seven year old because i'm an idiot um
no uh no i have so and i do have three
children
and um do you get three different
perspectives there at those different
age groups
it's great to see because believe it or
not the 20 year old
is concerned about climate but not as
much as the 14 year old
and the seven-year-old is a full-blown
activist
so you know when i see these questions
from middle schoolers i think it's
fantastic
that they are already keyed in on this
as a true issue of concern so
it's fantastic oh welcome back to
star talk this episode is from a virtual
live stream cosmic queries with the
broward county
youth climate summit that's broward
county florida
we've been talking about the science of
climate change i've got my co-host chuck
nice
and our special guest climatologist
gavin schmidt
and we've been answering questions from
the students themselves
about the future of the climate crisis
so let's get back to it all right chuck
keep it coming
all right let's keep going now um if
you've just joined us
probably you should have been there from
the beginning but if you just joined us
we are at the broward county youth
climate summit third annual
and we're talking to floridians about
climate
and we've got with me gavin schmidt
senior advisor to nasa
on climate and director the goddard
institute for space studies i didn't say
it at the beginning
but goddard it's abbreviated guess and
gis
specializes in many things
but especially climate on planets what
is what the atmosphere is doing
what the environment around what you
know solar
heating cooling within the atmospheres
turbulence
all of this so earth as just another
planet
can give you a cosmic perspective on the
things that can go wrong
on a in a planetary atmosphere all right
so gavin tell me two planets where stuff
really went wrong
in the past so that was that was that's
an easy one
uh so you've got venus and you've got
mars uh so
uh venus what one is the others two are
right they're right they're
adjacent to us okay yeah and so uh
venus may well have been the first
habitable planet in the solar system
uh and for a long time for about a
billion years
may have been able to maintain water at
the surface
uh but as the sun got brighter over time
it you know it and it's still getting a
little bit brighter
uh the uh the oceans uh evaporated the
hydrogen was lost and uh and it's turned
into a hell hole
where uh lead will melt on the surface
so
um but you can i did the calculation
gavin i did the
yes it can melt lead fine but you could
cook a 16 inch pepperoni pizza
on your windowsill in three seconds so
that's
that's that that that's an advantage you
see there's a there's a silver lining to
this
high temperature planet exactly except
that you
you yeah your charred remains will have
a delicious meal
you be vaporized too and ignoring that
complication yes
it would be an awesome pizza oven that's
all i'm saying but but like i said
it might have been the first habitable
place in the uh in the solar system for
about uh for about a billion years
how about mars now mars uh
now we you know we see evidence for
water on mars
and uh and so we think that at some
point mars
uh a little bit more recently than venus
was uh was habitable there was there was
sufficient water on the
surface to uh to to have running water
and so we're trying to work out
uh what combination of of atmospheric
uh composition could have could have led
to that um
but uh that that that is that is long in
the past
and uh uh you know and now obviously
uh mars is extremely dry uh it's lost
whatever i mean it still has some uh
atmosphere but it's it lost a lot of its
atmosphere it lost a lot of its water
um and now is uh is is does not have
very much of a greenhouse effect
um and uh and is very cold and uh
uh it has pretty sunsets um and you
would be hard-pressed
to cook a pepperoni pizza at any time
[Music]
right now on mars okay so mars doesn't
have any running water anymore but it
once did
but it has pretty sunsets so chuck
there's it so those are the two reasons
one to go to venus and want to go to
mars get a pretty good job
yes so that's right
you know no air but god the views
the views are beautiful the views are
gorgeous
so breathe enjoy those views
all right okay here we go
i love this question from
sierra e and sierra e
is in the ninth grade at coral springs
high school
and sierra is not playing around
she wants to know this what kind of
jobs are there for people
interested in climate and climate
studies
sierra i don't let me just say sierra
i'm already proud of you okay you're not
only looking
to solve the existential crisis that
faces all of mankind
but you're like how do i make some money
off of this
[Laughter]
i love you sierra that's the way to
think
so there's some there's some great uh
there's some great opportunities um
so the the kinds of tech jobs uh that
are gonna be important
are things like smart grid technology
storage technology
uh renewables uh all of those things
that are gonna be growing
uh enormously the energy stores the next
few decades
when you say energy storage um and then
you've got
uh you know the adaptation part of it
you know how do
you uh help cities and
agriculture uh plan for the changes
to come i you know there's there's a lot
of uh social science
uh issues there there's a lot of politic
politics uh
involved there um but without those
people
like all the technology in the world
doesn't help us
right things need to be deployed uh
things need to be used
that you know what what is it how is
that change going to happen
uh and the people that are making that
change or helping enable that change
they're going to be the most important
people uh around and
uh and so those aren't necessarily stem
jobs that you know they could be public
service they could be
um urban planning uh they could be uh
you know people who are interested in in
sewage and septic tanks and like dealing
with
um the legacy of what we've built now
and the infrastructure that's in uh
that's it that's in peril right now and
how to make it resilient and and how to
deal with the problems that are going to
come
yeah gavin that's a brilliant brilliant
answer there and i had not
fully grocked how
interdisciplinary climate science
in our society would be because right
you said you got you need the scientist
you're among them you need the policy
people you're among them but
but a cool invention that pulls us off
of fossil fuels
into other forms of energy that would be
industry but then you still have to
deploy it so you get the politics
i love it everybody can get a piece of
that pie
it's it's a problem that affects every
single area
of our lives which means that if you
think of it in terms of systems change
then whatever you do
in life if you relate it to climate
there is an application
there you go so and by the way i have
not
fully grocked the word grot
what the hell was that it's a geek word
and i i forgot what its origin is but if
you look it up behind mine
it was a robin heinlein thank you uh it
comes from science fiction it's spelled
g-r-o-k
it has to do with wrapping your head
around an issue or a problem
and coming to terms with it within
yourself possibly
then being able to do something about it
the doctor's
good there did i get that right gavin i
think so i'm trying to remember the book
in which it first appeared um it might
have been the moon is a horse mistress
but uh but i i forget the details
but it was it was very big in the 1960s
and 70s so
well there you go kids there's a youth
among us that's that's where it comes
from
this is when you know that you're in the
secret astrophysics club
where you can actually use the word grog
and then know it's freaking origins
this is you're seeing the secret geek
speak
that these scientists have with one
another
okay
someone someone look that up where which
book do they come from live long and
prosper yeah
okay right thank you for bringing back
down to my level
thank you all right let's move on
back let's not move on let's go back
to sean d who has a a
very sobering question he's at grade six
at um margate middle school
uh and shaun dee wants to know this
what do you fear will happen in the
future
if we take no action
all right so there goes gavin give us
the apocalyptic scenarios
um well let me i'll start off i'll start
off
i'll start off and i'll hand off to you
the broward county youth climate summit
in 20 years will be held under water
yeah it's not that's not funny
okay i'm sorry what was funny was
you say hey that's not funny
okay um i know so i mean like
if if we if we don't rise to this moment
then the sea will rise to this moment oh
wow you know if if if if there's a
bumper sticker for you get off
right now that's a t-shirt that's a
t-shirt that's a t-shirt a bumper
sticker a meme
yeah okay all right wait wait say that
again
so we can get we can get a meme shot of
you yeah right there i'm gonna get a
screenshot okay
go say it again uh
if we don't rise to this moment the seas
will rise to this moment
wow boom boom that's beautiful mike
dropped
we're done here no but i mean but
you know this this is this is a serious
question i mean like the the
the worst case scenarios the that we've
plotted out you know if we go
if we don't do anything we just like we
just we just burn all of the fossil
fuels that we can we burn all of the
coal all of the oil the methane hydrates
the
the tar sands the oil shales all the
rest of it
uh we we could have an impact
on this planet that has not been seen in
in
tens of millions of years maybe maybe
even maybe even longer
uh the the anthropocene the period that
we're now
creating uh would be so
far out of like the normal
bounds of of climate variability that
quite frankly we don't even know what
kind of a planet that would be
right we're talking about you know if
yeah
something more recent like the the last
ice age right which was only 20
000 years ago and that was caused by you
know wobbles in the earth's orbit
uh that was about yeah eight to nine
degrees fahrenheit
cooler than today right the worst
case scenarios if we just don't do
anything and burn everything that we can
find
uh that's about eight to nine degrees
fahrenheit
warmer than where we are now right and
the last ice age think about that you
know
uh massive ice sheets across the whole
of north america
mammoths and uh a very very different
planet
and and then kind of like flip that and
say well well what kind of planet would
it be if it was that much warmer
and we we don't know we don't know what
kind of planet that would be
uh it would be one that uh that we
and our current society would be would
be in trouble
like we have so much stuff next to the
coast we have so many
expectations you know our agriculture
you know where we grow things how we
grow things depends on the climate where
we are if things shift
such a degree then all of those
anticipations all of those expectations
are worthless wait wait yeah you said so
we have so much stuff
near the coast you're talking about new
york
city i mean new york and harbors and
you know how you know our world is a
connected world you know
around miami like but
shanghai and calcutta and bombay
mumbai uh you know chen zhen
london paris uh all of these places are
actually very close
to the coasts and uh you know and if you
think that
uh you know our heritage uh
such as it is should be worth preserving
then
you know not doing anything about
climate change is not the way to
maintain that so now um as we talk about
the loss of these coastal cities
is is there a way to target climate
change so that we could just take out a
few places that perhaps
that we don't want around anymore
i'm joking gavin that's a joke did you
see his face
kneel if he had a sign that said joke on
it then i would know
[Laughter]
welcome back to star talk this episode
is from a virtual live stream cosmic
queries
with the broward county youth climate
summit
in florida and we've been talking about
the science of climate change
with my co-host chuck nice and our
special guest
climatologist gavin schmidt
and we've been answering questions from
the students themselves about the future
of this climate crisis
in which we find ourselves so let's get
right back to it
all right so let's um let's go to
natalya p
she's in 11th grade over at west broward
high school
and um she's looking at this from a
policy standpoint
what are some laws that could be enacted
in order to slow down climate change
so is there anything that we can do
that we should ask our governments to do
to take ourselves yeah so i'm part of
the government so i have to be a little
bit careful here
uh so you know i can give my my personal
opinion obviously you know nasa doesn't
really
have much of an impact on uh on on laws
and policy directly but
you know but my personal uh view is that
you know
there are laws that that exist that that
are pushing us in the right direction
uh things like renewable standards uh
for uh for electricity
uh things like um uh
you know encouraging uh electric
vehicles uh
over internal combustion vehicles um
a price on carbon uh is something that
nudges everything in in the right
direction so
these things are difficult to enact
and you know and there's a lot of
politics uh behind what actually does
get enacted
um but but even like even things that
you think might be trivial like
building codes you know you can do a lot
with
uh improving building codes so that they
take account
of not just the climate changes that
you've had but the climate changes that
we're going to have
uh we can we can make um
rules that make buildings uh
use less energy and made with more uh
resilient uh
structures i mean so so we can both um
legislate to improve resilience um and
to reduce uh um energy wastage
uh so you know laws on uh if
standards for refrigerators you know i
mean the fact that
we've had uh if more efficient
refrigerators for
for the last uh 50 years
has saved an enormous number of
power stations from ever being built
right so
uh so efficiency gains can be helped
like the cafe standards
uh where they're looking at the at the
miles per gallon of the
of the vehicle fleet uh all of those
things uh are pushing us in the right
direction
all right that's hopeful very nice good
stuff
we like that all right let's um alice
oh by the way so so west broward high
school so go bobcats
oh right why know that i don't know but
go bobcat all right go ahead alessandra
m is a fifth grader at tradewinds
elementary school
and she's got a good question about
what what does global warming
have to do with severe weather events
like storms and heat waves droughts
and hurricanes so that
i love that because because gavin i mean
think about it if you just
if you're just thinking all right it's
one degree warmer in the world
yeah the fl the temperature fluctuates
so much more than that from between day
and night
why how could one degree matter to
anything else that's going on on this
planet
so uh so really that's a that's a
question of
of how things change on average and how
that gets translated into things that we
think of more as weather
um and that's a that's a great question
uh because first tell us the difference
between it's not always weathering
climate just
just spend a minute right the difference
between those so so yeah so so whether
i mean you know it's it's what's
happening today it's my what
what's happening next week it's
changeable it's kind of chaotic
um and and climate is really the average
of
of all of that over you know averaged
over many years and
looking at the statistics over many
years um
and uh there isn't
uh it's it's it's not it's not totally
obvious how these things
um uh connect uh but we now have a large
enough climate change signal
that we're starting to see how those
things connect so so let me give you
some
some of the pathways by which the these
connections happen
right so as the planet gets warmer right
it's warmed more than a degree celsius
so it's almost two degrees fahrenheit
uh at this point in the last 100 years
or so
uh the amount of water vapor in the
atmosphere increases
right so so it turns out that uh you
increase the uh the water vapor by about
10
with that amount of temperature change
right so so there's now 10
more water in the air than there used to
be
and if you think about uh storms and if
you think about
uh rain systems uh what you're doing
there is you're gathering up a lot of
quite moist air you're pushing it up and
then it all rains out
and if there's more water in the air
more water vapor in the air
when you squeeze it all together and you
push it up it comes out and it comes out
more and stronger and so what we've seen
um by the way that's just what
floridians want they want more humid air
well i mean so it is getting more humid
and you can you can track that in the in
the weather statistics in miami
uh as well um but yeah so so you have
more humid air and you have more intense
rainfall and you can see that
uh happening uh not just uh associated
with
big storm events like like hurricanes uh
but you can see it more generally
uh when you have a front coming through
uh you know kind of from the pacific
side to the atlantic side
uh you can see that the the statistics
of rain are pushing us towards
more intense rainfall um and
we discussed it earlier you know the the
temperatures themselves
uh in the ocean are leading to uh more
intense
uh storms in the uh in the atlantic
because the heat
uh of the water is is really the the
fuel that drives
uh the hurricanes and so we're seeing
more intense uh hurricanes
uh happening because of those
temperatures as well and obviously
as things get wait gavin if it's if it's
one degree on average
that means in some places it'll be much
more than that
correct right so uh so the places that
are warming the most actually
are in the high latitudes in in the um
in the arctic it's warmed
you know three four some places five
degrees
uh so that's just where we need us
but we're seeing but we're seeing quite
clear warming in the uh
in the tropical tropical atlantic uh
that's one of the places where
most of the hurricanes start off and so
so that's kind of
juicing them up um a little bit
um and obviously you know if the
temperatures are warming and
you know weather is that kind of noise
on top of that you're going to see
more heat waves you know more days over
90 degrees more days over 100 degrees
um and and you can see that happening uh
you know all around all around the world
you know from australia
through to uh to the us to europe to
japan to asia
uh you know we had um you know massive
heat waves in in uh
in siberia last summer uh you know
siberia not a warm place
but they had like 100 degrees above the
arctic circle
uh that's not usual right um in fact
it may even be unique uh and so a
new vacation spot a new vacation spot
siberia
sunny cyber lots of beachfront property
there
um well we only have a few minutes left
let's see if we can get a few
uh squeezed in there and gavin is going
to be a lightning round so real quick
give me a sound your best sound bite
answer go chuck
uh this is for uh well we're gonna
switch gears here because um
this is from carlos b and tyler b
i don't know if they're related uh pines
middle school and pioneer
middle school respectively great seven
and six
um what got you interested in being an
astrophysicist planetary scientist
author
and science communicator that's for both
of you
uh thanks for asking about being a
comedian there tyler
appreciate that carlos uh and then tyler
b
says what inspired you to do what you do
so what got you interested in the
specific work that you do and what made
you
go to science in the first place i i
don't know how sound biteable this is so
we're probably gonna have to end on
these questions
so gavin why don't you go
um for me i i started with mathematics
and uh and it was the joy of just like
kind of solving things and
uh and solving puzzles and then uh and
then i got into
things that actually meant things to
people and i
realized that you could solve problems
that people would appreciate and
they would care about and the more that
i've done
and the more that people care and the
more i'm able to talk to people
uh about these things uh the more
excited and the more interested i got in
the science that i was doing
so you got good feedback on your
ambitions
i did yeah that's a very important thing
because not
not everyone if you like math and then
you have a peer group that says you like
math you what do you you know that could
turn a lot of people off if they still
want to sort of hang out with the cool
kids
and by the way if that happens to you
anyone listening uh they're just jealous
that you're good at math don't don't
fall for it
now and chuck is it true that when when
you were a kid if you're
if you're cracking up in class the
teacher says
you if you keep this up you'll only
amount to be being a comedian
or something absolutely yeah uh i've had
that
said to me like what do you think you
are a comedian i'm like hmm
[Laughter]
uh so for me i might my profile is well
known i think because it's written i've
written about it and spoken about it i
was nine years old and a first
trip to my local planetarium the hayden
planetarium and in fact when i sign off
this show
my tagline is keep looking up that was a
famous tagline
uh was called the star hustler from the
miami planetarium
for many many years um and he
he was the head of the planetarium and
he had a show on
a short bid on pbs giving sort of that
week's night sky at um
what was his name jack remembered in a
minute and so he signed off
but he died several years back and i say
somebody's got to carry that forward
so i i carry his legacy whenever i sign
off i say keep looking up
so planetariums were can be a tremendous
force
of influence on people's ability
interest in looking up but also
astrophysics just the universe in
general is a gateway
science it's a gateway science because
if you're interested in that
then you find out oh my gosh i need to
there's biology there there's
engineering that make the
satellites there's there's uh there's
physics there's chemistry
and so you come for the universe and you
stay for the whole rest of that
smorgasbord of science and i looked up
at the night sky in the planetarium and
i said oh my gosh
the the limitless discovery
that awaits us is what attracted me
and to communicate science i agree with
gavin here if you tell somebody
something
and they like it and they want more
that's kind of that's reinforcing
and then you find something else to tell
them that's really cool and interesting
about your field and as carl sagan once
said
when you're in love you want to tell the
world
so i think we got to call it quits there
oh my gosh this was fun and this is this
is our cosmic queries format
and i'm delighted that we got asked by
the broward county
school system to bring our cosmic
queries format
into your universe because that's what
we do and it's what we love to do
and and gavin always great to have you
on star talk
always a pleasure and we've got to make
sure that uh that the president of the
united states will
have your ear with the head of nasa and
so
if stuff doesn't go right we'll blame
you okay
[Music]
that's fair that's not fair that's
totally fair and
and chuck it's always good to have you
thanks for uh
bringing us a force of levity into this
world because sometimes we need it
otherwise
we'll just cry it's always a pleasure
i'm just saying and let me end by by
declaring
that i don't know in the history of the
world if there's ever been a community
of adults
who upon looking at the next generation
said
i can't wait till you all take over to
fix this stuff
take a look at what adults have said
about the next generation for the past 4
000 years and we've always worried about
what the next generation would be
and do but maybe for the first time the
opposite
is the case so you all hurry up get
older
and gain the power we need to fix this
world
save us children i'm neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist as
always bidding you
to keep looking up
[Music]
you